hello and welcome to the show my guest
today is from Italy and he came here to
Germany originally in 1998 to get his
PhD at the European molecular biology
laboratory in Heidelberg Giovanni
Frechette Oh is a neuroscientist and an
author he now lives here in Berlin where
he works for the Institute for Advanced
Study hello welcome to the show my first
question is very simple
what is the Institute for Advanced Study
what goes on there it's heaven imagine
imagine a set of villas in the woods
around a lake where you can go and read
study and discuss ideas with other
like-minded people it's an institute
that attracts scholars from all
disciplines it can be philosopher in
study mathematics physics biology
sociology you can be a musician a writer
or an artist you're invited for a year
and the only obligation you have is to
have meals together with your colleagues
and talk about something intelligent
most of the time you say you were
invited how did that come about you are
a fellow for a year you get a letter you
some somebody nominates you or you can't
apply you can also apply as big as quite
a few both both both ways and then you
invited for a year and you spend 10
months in total there and the only
expectation is that you you produce
something at the end but well what do
you have to produce or tell us mostly
most people can't to write a book and
then and but we increasingly have also
biologists who come to the business
school
League I used to be a fellow was a
fellow in 2007 when I first came to when
I first moved to Berlin and and I work
at the Institute has staff so I'm
responsible for a program called College
for Life Sciences a program within the
Institute that attracts young young
biologists scholars from the life
sciences who want to be immersed in this
interdisciplinary environment so to gain
time to think about the research but you
don't teach them I don't teach them I I
mentor them I select them together with
her with a board of course and then when
they are at least as a Dementor them I
talk to them we exchange texts and
readings follow more or less I follow
them through the fellowship but they got
the ultimate freedom to - to spend their
time but I say please cities have an i
and who funds this it is funded both by
the city of Berlin and also federally by
the state of Germany and there are also
some private donors who sometimes all
generously give so it's not in the
international organization it is
primarily it is a German institution but
it is international in the sense that it
that it attracts international scholars
do you have contacts with other
Institute like-minded institutions
around the world and exchange things yes
absolutely
there are other Institute for Advanced
Studies within Germany and then the
visit chefs colleague this is the German
name also has links with other
institutes for Advanced Studies in
Europe and the rest of the world then we
try to attract scholars from all corners
of the world and all pathways of wisdom
okay that is being say I mean is Germany
the best place to be a scientist Germany
Germany and is is very good with science
I find it's very well supported
very good
factor and good funding you're also one
of the founders of the European
neuroscience and society Network now
what's the purpose of this slightly
different I assume yes this is something
that I started when I when I still lived
in London
this was no idea the colleagues and I
had to bring neuro scientists closer to
two other thinkers from just colors from
the humanities or from sociology from
social studies of science because we
were very interested in the societal
impact that neuroscience has and so for
five years we had money from the
European Science Foundation to organise
meetings to set up schools and and try
to educate especially young scholars to
think differently early on in their
career neuroscience is a field that has
enormous societal implications and
cultural implications so instead of just
working in the lab and coming out to
your your dedicated project we
encouraged them to open their minds and
to exchange evidence I mean tell me a
little bit about neuroscience in that I
remember I met a neurologist once I was
very impressed by him because the first
thing he said to me is by the way we
only know 20% of what's going on up here
80% is guesswork theory is that true or
it was a few years back it is it is I
think it's important to be humble in
neuroscience it's a fascinating field of
research but it encompasses so much of
who we are it's about our movement
speech language emotions behavior memory
and personality and perhaps everything
under the umbrella of consciousness
there's a lot to grapple with it's a lot
to explain is it frustrating though
there's eight you know we don't know
what it's all a gray matter here it's
not it's just as fascinating as it is it
is frustrating at times but whatever you
do
you should never give up you know a
study the brain because it will be a
contribution to a larger written a book
about it called how we feel with a
subtitle that says what neuroscience can
and can't tell us about our emotions
that's quite interesting because you are
saying yes there's lots it can tenants
as well but there is stuff that it can
tell us yes I decided to write a popular
science book for everybody to read and
appreciate all the great things about
science and about the science of the
brain but also be conscious and aware
about the limitations so what
neuroscience can tell us about emotions
is mostly the experience of emotion so
we sorry periods it cannot it cannot
tell us about the experience yes so
really how we feel when we are going
through an emotion there's something so
personal so subjective and so we we can
now look inside the brain to see what
happens in a certain condition in
certain circumstances we can measure all
kinds of hormones look at the genes
proteins but ultimately in during our
daily lives that's something you know
what we feel that's something that
science cannot describe in detail but
that is also okay you need something
else too
we look inside the brain a little more
in a minute but right now let's have a
look Ram Berlin with Giovanni right now
the town has got so much to offer this
so much culture it's got the best
orchestra in the world
fantastic museums it attracts a lot of
artists especially visual artists
writers and so you can produce a lot and
feel the excitement about producing on
if there's one thing that I have
cultivated a lot while I was here
that's theatre there's a pleasure to to
dream for a couple of hours and be
captured into a different world
Shakespeare sonnet this is my favorite
show here at the Torino number a lot of
Shakespeare love the sonnets very much
and because you know six times in total
this is typical typically Germanized
I'll have a piece of the Schwarz out
there Kish they say thank you thank you
thank you here we go got the cake
it's a challenge they like using
cherry's as you know something sour in
the middle of the top of the cake and
and for me that's something I can't I
can't really deal with
this is the pressure thing to do after
work after a hard day's work coming to a
lake renting a boat and do some rolling
this is perfect it's just what you need
it is important to me to spend some time
close to this is the water reminds me of
home reminds me of Sicily a lake is not
exactly the Mediterranean Sea but it's
good enough for Berlin this between a
good mood
don't almost there
in line parking in line parking is a
challenge
my guests they're parking his boat
indeed I want to come back to the book
okay in a minute but I have to talk to
you about German cuisine that was a huge
piece of cake
wasn't believable yes because I know you
love this country very much but you do
have a problem with the cuisine January
it's not just the cake it's not just a
cake correct I unlike German food I like
to have been a schnitzel sometimes well
maybe that's Austrian but I liked you
know the sausages and cabbage I like
that so Kerry Kerry would easily yeah in
Berlin but a few things you know
especially and about cakes or coffee and
tea and I find very difficult for me
for instance they serve tea in a glass
and I had a problem with that
because and I was very surprised they
would serve tea in a glass always asking
do you have a handle because if you
don't have a handle you squat your
fingers you can't actually drink that
tea oh no I've never as an Englishman
tea drinking I've got that's true
yes yes now the cakes are huge add a lot
of cream they like using cream a lot but
you said about the cake being sour now
it if I could take you to task it
Italian cakes are only sweet French
cakes are sometimes I mean tart Osito is
not always sweet so it hadn't cakes
they're often very so easy and where I
come from Sicily is a lot of sugar
there's a lot of sugar at Wiess and we
even have type of syllabear called
granita which is huge injection of sugar
into your system but it's delicious and
sometimes we have it for breakfast when
it's too hot together with a brioche
really yes okay and you don't you've got
a source problem and a cream problem
here I heard a lot of cream they use it
everywhere and the sources are not thick
enough so when you eat pasta with a
German sauce you need to defend yourself
with a napkin
or learn and train better than or two
and that's the guess presumably I mean
you live here so you don't starve no I
like cooking for me I should watch these
at this point that I think there is
another reason why your bet where is it
yes here it is oh no that's the wrong
why does that do that machines ha your
tenth birthday party a lovely picture
and there's a cake and that's a cake and
is that mum or dad or mom and dad mom
and dad cakes were important for
birthday parties there was a team they
they may cake together mum responsible
for the bulk of it so she would make the
cake but Dad was responsible for the
decoration and the final touch and every
year was they tried to make it different
yeah now let's come back to the book now
we've sorted out cuisine what can i I
mean I'm intrigued if I can ask basic
question what can science then tell us
about our emotions today you said there
are things they can't tell us you told
us that before what can it tell us then
that's a that's a great deal that where
we know well first of all science tells
us that emotions our bodily reactions
emotions are all about our body and it's
not just the brain its garden by the
brain but emotion involves you know our
respiration and that blood circulation
we sweat for instance so and we also
communicate emotionally through our body
it's all governed by the brain but it
involves um the entire body we know
about what parts of the brain are
involved for certain emotions we cannot
map them so closely but we know more or
less where things go on and we can look
inside the brain for a technique called
functional magnetic resonance imaging
slowly we are finding out what genes are
involved but we always need to remember
that there many many many many genes
involved an underlying one emotion we're
looking we can look at behavior in
animals for you know forms of the
emotion so it is it is for sure
a fascinating world the one can learn a
lot from um but for instance when we
talk about the the fMRI the the imaging
it is still for a lot of money has been
invested in it it is still sketchy you
know we can't tell exactly where where
motion is you know it's being felt and
also it's not just one area for it but
various areas will be involved one of
the chapters in your book is about grief
and I recently read that grief has been
quantified that if he goes on longer
than two weeks it becomes abnormal and
it's considered depression and needs to
be treated I mean surely a time limit
can't be put on grief I mean yes there's
no rhyme or reason to how long you know
one octave grieved for the loss of
somebody green is the price we pay has
human beings for loving somebody it's
the natural price we pay and you what
you just mentioned is a move by the
American Psychiatric Association and it
is also a cultural cultural event if you
like perhaps you know emotions are
bodily reactions but culture contributes
to that it is true now if you grieve for
longer than two weeks you are entitled
to earn a diagnosis of depression to be
considered depressed society doesn't
want you to be depressed and there can
be in pharmaceutical industries trying
to sell drugs there's a lot of interest
in that for sure to sell you know
antidepressants I mean let's go and
there's a chapter on guilt and I must
ask you about that I mean in principle
it's it's good that we feel guilt isn't
it otherwise we'd have no morals
yes yes all emotions have a function so
they have evolved within us for millions
of the earth so all the emotions have a
function the function of guilt is for us
not to not to repeat the same mistakes
however we go back to cancer here
because you know what what do we feel
when we feel guilt what happens when we
feel guilt we may perhaps located in the
brain or see what if it's the frontal
part of the brain that is active when we
have a feeling of guilt but in certain
certain contexts do not approach on on
on certain actions so we will be feeling
guilty for something once in one society
but not in another society so we are
equipped to feel it but the cultural
plane plays a role you talking about one
society another talking about this
society in Germany Germany's had its
fair share of collective guilt from
historical point of view do you think
it's dealt with it well if it's dealt
with it with it well I I see a lot of
guilt around I must say and isn't it
it's not beyond the collective memory
which is crucial and very important we
must distinguish between our personal
and the collective the does play a role
I see guilt is a very widespread emotion
yeah I must say perhaps I mistake get a
guilt for care you know they the Germans
want to do things well so if something
doesn't know goes it goes wrong and they
feel guilty for it and they you know
they're admittedly apologetic for
something that went that went wrong I
remember entering a shop once and buying
a present for friends and the shopkeeper
instead of welcoming my purchase said oh
well I don't have the box for what you
just picked that was an expression
yeah guilt effort and yet they were
trying to sell you something doesn't
matter yeah let's move on to joy yes
there now I'm and in the chapter on joy
music becomes very important I mean I
showed this with a picture but ask you
how important is music in your life now
here's a side of my guest you wouldn't
have thought here isn't a rock band
this is graduate school Heidelberg
through at the end of the PhD colleagues
and I from the band will recalled the
pranks and so we we play we cut it you
know other bands and I was singing
playing the guitar and music his is
emotion its release the Leo Tolstoy said
this is the shorthand of emotions it
really crypsis it talks directly to to
us and to our bodies so it is only
natural I mean it's important in your
life and you say it's very important
with emotions and with science as well
it's but you know yes it's lovely we are
discovering what goes on I mean what a
lot about brain and and and music at
every level so what happens when we hear
it to my week and we like it when we
don't like it for instance what happens
when we when we when we feel the chills
in our bodies we are sitting under in an
orchestra room of the Philharmonic and
Berlin and we feel the chills so we know
more or less what goes on there but
there's still a lot there's still along
to this company it brings us very nicely
to our next report let's go to the Max
Planck Institute here in Berlin where
they've been doing experiments with
musicians to see basically how their
brains synchronize with each other when
they play together
Johanna zinger loves listening to music
but she's also interested in the
scientific side of what's happening when
musicians play together to successfully
create a harmonious sound the brains of
the players have to be coordinated in
pursuit of a common goal the researcher
believes that this neuro synchronicity
occurs when the brains of musicians
playing together create a neurological
meta network according to her the
phenomenon can be described as a kind of
communal brain everybody has seen images
of brain waves at the doctor's office or
on TV you can picture them in a very
simple way as waves and when the two
guitarists are playing together their
brain waves are oscillating in the same
way that doesn't necessarily mean that
the peaks and valleys of the waves come
at exactly the same time but that the
intervals between the peaks and valleys
are the same and swishing banging on
ceiling Big Lie supply these guitarists
often feel a communal brain at work when
they play together you fill it with
certain processes and when you play
faster or slower at some point the
dynamics just work automatically fast
passing what happens in our brain when
we're playing together I'm really
curious to find out I find it
fascinating vocally she doesn't I see
admission
the research team found that the duo's
brainwaves synchronize when they play a
duet together as you had a speculum
fiamma's it's nonsense i'm ionship you
know I'm a singer now wants to know
whether the waves also oscillate in
tandem when viola VISAA and duncan
Taylor are playing different parts
in this scenario their two brains have
to coordinate continuously
Duncan plays the introductory bars even
before the two-part section of the piece
begins his brain waves are oscillating
in tandem with violas a spectacular
result we've observed synchronization
both within each of the individual
brains and between them what's
interesting about this is that the
synchronization doesn't remain the same
throughout the piece that you are
playing instead they are particularly
synchronized at certain points in it
especially when they start a section
together we believe that these moments
of coordination between the two are very
significant and that this is why the
synchronization between the brains then
becomes stronger even octaves and
corners at soondae on a stack of it a
neurological network also appears when
several musicians play together at this
experimental concert the brain waves as
some of the audience members are being
recorded as well and there are
indications that their brains are also
involved in or are responding to the
network
it does rather look is there there all
the hairdressers waiting for a haircut
being serenaded by katate I mean do you
think there's gonna be a lot more
progress in the future with this area in
that you're very musical yourself you
love music you love culture generally
and you say there is an association of
science and we do you think that's
something that will progress much more
in the future yes I think so and I hope
so at the same time there's a there's a
lot more attention on positive emotions
lately so joy belongs to to that and
music can help us achieve joy can play
an instrument we can sing and this will
perhaps help us in going to a into a
better mood and it's not just something
trivial and to say and your body trains
and the more you the more you smile
for instance the more you'll be likely
to smile in the future and and and and
it's also better for your health rather
than being grumpy this is this is proven
this this this we know what is the same
with the singing isn't it they've proven
I don't know one bet called the the
things you must probably do well that
when you sing you things come out in
your body that make you make you
positive make you enjoy just pheromones
or something else in general but you
know this is something that even the
fathers of psychology used to say
William James said if you're in the
woods and you're afraid whistle it
sounds trivial because he might be in
danger but you will but the body will
respond you know to to what to what you
have decided and will you know will
follow the order okay so whistling about
training yourself you know to divert
from negative negativity to something
more positive mindfulness to now it's
all very positive that and we've got a
signed copy of my guest javonni for us
set those book to give away it's called
how we feel I haven't read it all but
what I have read is fascinating and a
real insight into so many things about
our behavior anyway if you'd like
to have a copy of this drop us a line to
insight at dwae and you could be the
lucky winner feel joyous feel positive
it could be you so drop us a line in
sight at DW de I want to go back like a
good psychotherapist now that you come
from I've said Italy but actually from
Sicily from Emma and now am i
pronouncing this and from Franco Ponte
first the font in francofonte but they
have got it right on the map and what
was it like to you said you missed the
water in our report because obviously or
in Sicily what else do you miss from
there apart from the capes
family cakes from perform toes on the
hill you get a very very nice view on
the Mount Etna on the volcano and
francofonte
is don't there only orange groves it's
full of oranges and very good oranges so
I missed that
especially during during the winter it
was the small town where to grow up it
was fifteen thousand inhabitants bay was
also not far from from from the sea and
I really enjoyed it it's got her it's
it's mentioned twice and an opera cover
Lydia it was to Canada nobody knows
about my hometown but opera lovers might
it's where the main character goes to
buy wine but back sometimes some time
ago
I wonder about the how can I put this
the other cliche one might have about
Italy and cavalier a rustic and as made
me think of it this is a dangerous place
to be where you come from is that or is
that just a total cliche partly as I
grew up as I grew up I should show this
just at the same time photo as you're
growing up you say as you grow up let's
show the photo cute photo that you said
does various singing three four years
old and through Cuza when we were
visiting my aunt my my my father sister
in
the and the garden yes over my parents
used to be reps energy energy place in
the 70s in the 80s
mafia was at the peak of its its
existence
so you occasionally might have you might
hear sirens and there would be shootings
and big towns but he no longer occurs
and we were safe
moving on to I think Venice ah if I've
got this right have I got this from yes
this right this is Venice in 1992 I was
five years old my family and I all went
to or to Austria and and we stopped we
stopped in Venice we drove we drove
there with it with the trailer and this
is a picture that dad took of my sister
and myself on ababa retro is perhaps the
best victory took a bus and they're
really fun words in the family so fun
one of that now and when did you
actually when did your interest in
science start when I was about 16 I
won't I've always wanted to do all sorts
of things that perhaps a doctor or we'll
all wanted to learn languages or study
literature and then 16 I read an article
in Scientific American about how genes
are expressed and and and how an embryo
develops and why do we have a leg where
we have it or the brain etc and I
thought there was something everybody
had to do and you hadn't done sort of
biology or sciences in school before
then when you read you know Regional
Research and you're fascinated by the
discovery and how they they discovered
that you know in school you detach
people learn what's there to learn but
if you read an original article makes it
all more exciting and that was the
moment when I decided to study biology
oh okay yeah I was 16
yeah now we have a questionnaire a
famous questionnaire on the program and
you you you if you answered it in great
detail being a scientist and I just want
to ask you really for now we'll talk
about it a bit more but um there's a
couple of things first of all I wanted
to ask you about the worst thing about
living in Germany your answer
I fell forward when you said the absence
of the Mediterranean Sea bar can't help
you there
but you said having to deal with the
gender of nouns oh yes
Mark Twain had it right in its in its
essay the awful German language I think
I will never get it right it's it's
tough it's a tough one sure okay
even if you've spoken German for some
time at least this is why we sure Jack's
position say the best thing about living
in Germany do you remember what you said
about the trains yes from Twila T having
grown up in Sicily for mid-year dear
there you can show up the platform and
know exactly when the train arrives is
indeed a gift it's marvelous I know it
is another cliche but from sometimes if
I'm about to catch a bus I look from the
window where the people have started to
guard the station they don't know I need
to come down because the bus really I
can't keep schedule Sarah I will never
look up but yeah but you know it will
arrive I know will arrive with people I
yeah and they come pretty regularly do
that's that's the thing as well one
thing we asked our guests as well as to
it make up your own categories and you
did make up a category you said your non
favorite German sentence it's getting
east how would we translate that's got a
soap and ooh can't do that tons about
reticence you know the first reaction is
of no and very rigidly so and but
perhaps without having really looked at
the problem from another perspective or
perhaps change change the plan this is
something that I have you know that I
clash a little bit okay okay and also
your favorite place in Germany so many
people put Berlin but actually you've
put Heidelberg what's so special about
Heidelberg where you studied for five
years about five years this was graduate
school
I'd never European molecular biology
laboratory as an enchanting place I was
coming from London so at the beginning
Heidelberg felt rather small but then
together with the rest of the class
you know the Graduate School
we were working hard and playing hard
too is full of nature and there's a
river you can you can hike you can run a
school of culture there's a film
festival lots of music it's very
international and I created an
established very good friendships there
well we have something for you now let's
have a look at what has to be one of
this country's loveliest cities the
American writer Mark Twain visited the
city of Heidelberg in 1878 and was
profoundly impressed writing I have
never enjoyed a view which had such a
serene and satisfying charm about it as
this one gives even today Heidelberg has
lost none of that satisfying charm
Hyderabad's best-known landmark is
located on conics tour here heidelberg
castle
resplendent on its hillside the ruins
Castle overlooks the old town which
survives the Second World War
unscathed
Heidelberg is a university town and a
fifth of its residents are students the
main street in the town is a shopping
precinct and open-air Museum in one the
neighborhood is steeped in history with
every winding lane leading to another
local landmark such as the Baroque
Jesuit Church the University of
Heidelberg is germany's oldest it's old
assembly hall was built in 1885 the
fresco shows Athena the Greek goddess of
wisdom
an aura of scholarship and learning
permeates the premises to mark the
university six hundred and twenty-fifth
anniversary the library got its pride
and joy on display the original codex
Manus the 14th century illuminated
manuscript is the single most
comprehensive source for love songs in
Middle High German
in the 16th century the university
opened up to Jensen kartha or students
prison where carousing students were
kept off the streets for up to four
weeks at a time and fed bread and water
on the northern side of the river net
car is highly compact Hill and the
philosopher's walk so-called because it
was here that Hyderabad's philosophers
and professors traditionally came to
walk and talk and enjoy the panoramic
views at one end is a monument to the
Romantic poet free pleasure Dylan and
his famous ode to Heidelberg
did you ever get thrown in that student
prison no like a nice I do believe
though that Berlin is where you prefer
to live now though for other reasons
what's so special about Berlin there it
is a large city
yeah the size is different and I like
you know it should be surrounded by a
lot of more people I wouldn't say Berlin
is so international of course it is but
it's not a cosmopolitan in town not yet
it's becoming and what why is that why
is it not it's not full of [ __ ] you know
not it's not ethnically diverse I would
say it's not like London it's not like
look that's that's the comparison I was
making but otherwise from the cultural
point of view Berlin is extremely
interesting and stimulating there's so
much art a lot of young people with with
great ideas and has become a harbor I
think for artists from all over Europe
or or or the world the orchestra is
fantastic yeah Patera
yeah now you you you just said you
worked in London you've work they've
been in Heidelberg in Berlin um are the
marked differences in styles the way
scientists the way the science community
works if you see what I mean
yes well I don't have a lot of
experience in Italy actually no because
I left before I entered you know the
world of research side left when I was
18 and my experiences are England and
Germany and I had a great time in both
both places
perhaps as far as I am concerned the you
know England and UK are even better when
it comes to science communication and
this encounter between science and and
and the arts there's a lot of interest
and you know bringing science to to the
public there's a great tradition yeah
your books in English yeah well is it
published in German as well it is also
poetess and germany is called the galue
scored okay
they changed the title but it's the same
but sort of works with what you're
saying that it
published in English it's had a it says
often illuminating some and inspired
right up there from the times they're
obviously showing are they showing more
interest there in that side of things as
well I mean did you say they're better
at it are they showing more interest -
oh yes it's going well I started
presenting the book at the Edinburgh
Festival last year when he when he came
out and I also sense a great response
when I give talks and when if I you know
if I presented in England I think it's
it's a book that I wrote thinking of uh
of uh of an Anglo Saxon audience there
are many references to that culture and
this is no what I could retain from
having lived there - um one thing I just
noticed in the press the other day we
haven't got a lot of time but the u.s.
announced it's about to invest 4.5
billion dollars in trying to crack the
code as to how the brain functions is
this possible - do do - not in not in
our lifetimes I'm afraid Robin but it is
it is a great initiative it reminds me
of what the investment in the decoding
of the genome mmm about 15 years ago in
the 90s and now we're decoding the brain
it is a daunting task but I find it
extremely important that even more and
more you know funds are devoted to do
this there would be it's a lot of
students will have jobs and it would be
you know what's next for you we're
almost out of time but what's I'm am I'm
working on another science book but I'm
also trying to finish our collection of
short stories and the started writing a
novel that will probably never finish
why don't you think you'll finish it but
you've got so you're and I know you
write poems as well and write theater
plays for theater yes here in Berlin yes
me twice a fascinating man I think
you'll agree ladies and gentlemen
Giovanni fat Seto thanks very much for
joining us
just remind you of the book once again
how we feel it is Faso's open my eyes to
many things I am them you can win this
if you write loser in sight at DWD
possibly win it I should say there's
only one winner it gives a lot of joy
we'll finish on that now it's roughly
thanks very much thank you until next
time bye bye